this is very interesting Donald Trump
said during an interview this week that
yes he is planning to get people a
second stimulus check Trump was
interviewed by Joe st. George he was
asked about a second stimulus check and
he said that that's the plan he wouldn't
say when or for how much let's take a
look at that bit of the interview I have
a lot of viewers in Florida Ohio
Wisconsin Michigan who are still
struggling economically served they
spent all of that first stimulus check
are you gonna get them a second stuff
yeah we are we are look we had this when
when are you gonna get it we had this
going better than anybody's ever seen
before we had the best job numbers the
best economics the best economy we've
ever had and then we had the virus come
in from China and that we're rebuilding
it again we will be doing another
stimulus package it'll be very good
it'll be very generous and how much how
much how much people want to know you'll
find out about it you'll flood when are
you gonna do it when you go to announce
I think over the next I think it's gonna
be bipartisan I think it's going to be
over the next couple of weeks probably
now this is fascinating for a few
different reasons you might remember
that about a month ago maybe it was five
weeks ago it was pretty clear that the
Trump administration didn't really have
the appetite for another round of
payments another stimulus check and I
think that there were two reasons for
that first of all there were so-called
economic concerns about the cost of
doing another stimulus check a lot of
the people on Trump's side politically
are a so-called debt and deficit hawks
even though they don't really understand
those those mechanisms economically but
it seemed that that was part of the lack
of appetite but maybe even more
importantly they were against committing
to a second round of stimulus checks
four to six weeks ago because they
wanted to pretend that everything would
be fine by now and back to normal and
that you simply wouldn't need another
round of stimulus checks now of course
this is very much not the case and in
fact a ton of people entitled to their
first check haven't even received it 35
million stimulus checks are still
outstanding as of mid-june and at the
same time Trump can't say or he won't
say how much money would be included in
the second stimulus and the reason
he can't say that is the truth is it's
not clear that Republicans want to do
another round of stimulus and to me this
signals what's going on behind the
scenes
Democrats want stimulus because
Democrats think people deserve it given
how bad the situation with the
coronavirus continues to be many
Republicans don't want another stimulus
because their so-called debt and deficit
hawks Trump only wants a second stimulus
because he sees the polls and he's
panicking and as more checks go out he
envisions that he is essentially buying
himself more votes that's really what's
going on here and there are even some
officials in the Trump administration
that are not on board with doing another
round of stimulus it's not clear
Republicans in the House are going to go
for it it's not clear Republicans in the
Senate are going to go for it either
there have been some internal
discussions where Trump has said
straight up
he believes sending out more checks will
help boost the economy and help him get
reelected in the fall like but period
full stop end of story which is exactly
what it seems to be to me
Stephen minuchin has been in favor of
another round of checks Trump's economic
adviser Larry Kudlow seems to have been
opposed Senate Majority Leader Mitch
McConnell has been against another round
of payments Democrats want even larger
payments than the first time around and
Donald Trump here seems to be with the
Democrats not for economic reasons not
for moral reasons but because he
believes sending checks out again will
help get him reelected in November Trump
is effectively trying to buy his way to
re-election with another round of checks
the right loves to attack the left as
wanting to buy people's votes with
things like health care and properly
funded education for example now those
arguments are quite silly what we're
talking about is establishing a well-run
Society given that we're one of the
richest countries in the world much like
many northern European countries have
been able to do but Trump is actually
saying allegedly behind the scenes if we
start sending checks out to people I'm
gonna get more people to vote for me now
the other thing here
is Trump maybe setting himself up to say
look I wanted another round of checks
but they wouldn't okay it they will be
framed as Democrats even though here
Democrats do want it and it seems like
it's Republicans that aren't actually
interested in terms of the timing
there's a bit of a conundrum July 3 to
17 is what's called a state work period
for the Senate meaning they will be in
their states rather than in Washington
DC so what this means is there's no way
this gets done before July 3rd I mean
we've got you know before July 3rd we
have the next three days then we've got
a weekend and then we have a few days
next week you're not gonna pass another
round of stimulus checks before next
Friday
that means the conversation won't even
really be meaningful until after the
Senate returns after July 17th so if
this process starts on July 17 when
could this even potentially be done are
we looking at August are we looking at
September and remember 35,000,000 still
haven't gotten their first check or
deposit which means that even if you get
this passed in late July or August you
could have people who still will have
not received their checks until close to
the presidential election in November so
I don't know whether it can even be done
it doesn't seem Trump wants it for any
reason other than he sees it as a way to
buy himself some votes and we also have
no idea what might even be going on by
the time that this actually gets done in
late July early August we may not even
have a break between waves 1 and 2 in
coronavirus as we see the virus
continues to rage in many states across
the country very unpredictable but
Donald Trump now panicking and saying
yeah yeah yeah let's get more checks to
people and a lot of this has to do with
the polls which I want to talk about
next one of our sponsors is privacy calm
they're giving you $5 when you sign up
for their completely free service at
privacy calm slash Pakman I've been
using privacy for a little over a year
now you've heard me talk about it before
it's a lifesaver and here's how it works
takes just a couple of minutes to set up
anytime you buy something online or on
the phone
instead of actually using your real
credit card number the privacy app and
the browser plugin let you give each
company a randomized virtual credit card
number that you create out of thin air
it'll even autofill the card number with
one click and the payment is taken out
of your checking account without the
merchant ever knowing your real
information so this allows you to keep
your banking information secure but also
to take control of your finances you can
create up to 12 of these virtual credit
cards a month you can set spending
limits you can freeze them you can
delete them any time you want so when
you do this it means you're not going to
be charged when you don't want to be
because you can destroy the virtual card
number right after using it which for
instance I love using free trials
because I know I won't be charged when
the trial is over if I use a virtual
credit card number you're keeping your
identity private by not telling
companies who you are you're keeping
your bank or credit card info protected
against data breaches and identity theft
and it's free there's no catch
whatsoever but if you want privacy also
offers a $10 a month plan that gives you
one percent cashback and lets you create
36 credit cards a month and a $25 a
month plan tailored more for small
businesses where you can create 60 card
numbers a month and much more but
definitely go ahead and at least get
started with a free plan you'll protect
your financial info companies can't
charge you unexpectedly and like I said
you'll get $5 to spend when you sign up
at privacy calm / Pakman